ومن الضحك ما قتل تخيلوا ان تصبح هذه
المقوله حقيقه لكن كيف عند استنشاق غازي
اكسيد النيتروز او اكسيد النيتروجين او ما
يعرف شعبيا بغاز الضحك تصل جزيئاته الى
الدماغ ويجعل من يستنشقه يشعر فورا
بالبهجه والتنميل في الجسم وعدم الشعور
بالالم والميل الى الهستيريا الخفيفه ليس
هذا فحسب بل يصل هذا الشعور الى مرحله
الضحك غير المتحكم فيه وهو سبب التسميه
فيما قد يشعر بعض مستنشقه بالقلق واحيانا
بنوبات الهلع هذا الغاز المكتشف عام
1772 له استخدام طبي كماده مساعده في
التخدير للعمليات الجراحيه فهو مزكن
للالام بشكل كبير وله استخدامات اخرى لدى
اطباء الاسنان والنساء والولاده ورغم ان
كل تاثيرات غاز الضحك مؤقته وت خلال دقائق
معدوده بعد التوقف عن استنشاقه الا ان
الاستخدام المتكرره لهذا الغاز خطر جدا
وهو ما دعى حكومات اوروبيه لاتخاذ اجراءات
قويه لحظره مؤخرا فهذا الغاز الذي وصف
بالقاتل يعمل على ازاحه الاكسجين من
الرئتين ويسبب عدم انتظام ضربات القلب
المفاجئه عندما يجري استنشاق الماده
بتركيز 100% كما يجعل المتعاطي له عرضه
للاصابه بفقر الدم اذ يسبب الغاز انخفاض
مستوى الهيموجلوبين هو امراضا اخرى ولهذا
اعلنت الحكومه البريطانيه توجهها لحظر بيع
غاز اكسيد النيتروس وذلك لعامه الناس في
اطار حمله واسعه للحد من السلوكيات
المعاديه للمجتمع